we're just getting word that from a  number-10 source that's saying that the  Prime Minister will call our EU leaders  tonight and that they want the October  31st deadline to stand so not asking for  delay the long way beyond that although  he's already sent a letter asking for a  delay so it all goes pert at perhaps to  Europe the EU Council President Donald  Tusk says he's consulting European  leaders on how to respond to the UK's  request for a brexit extension and added  that a No Deal brexit would never be the  e use decision the outgoing president of  the European Commission jean-claude  Juncker expressed his frustration though  calling brexit a waste of time and  energy